Wait, why does it just shift me over to
some random thing?
Yeah, the chat's just broken.
I see it on YouTube here.
That's so obnoxious, though.
Oh, stream not found. No YouTube event.
Hang on.
I really need something better than
reream.
Yeah. I
Huh.
Well, I'm going to leave the stream chat
up, I suppose, so I can see it on the
other monitor. Uh, it's not going to
show up here, though.
That's super annoying.
Freaking paid service just doesn't work
half the time.
Okay. So, here is
here's our forward bit.
Oh, wait. This is actually informative,
isn't it?
Yeah, I'll try to catch I'll try to
catch both platforms.
I don't know. It's just super annoying.
Like I for reference, I have this
dashboard that just like tries to
combine all the streams. Like it drops
messages. It's like I don't know if
anybody has a better alternative. By all
means,
I need to get some real stuff done on
this today, guys. So,
we take a look at this. This is
Did I get this right? 8.9 billion or is
it 890?
No, 890. Okay, look at this. Most of
these element wise kernels are in the
forward pass, right?
but then most of the kernels I believe
are actually in the forward path here
which would make sense.
So before we try to go write a um
before we go try to write a
custom kernel for everything.
Let's just see.
I'm going to actually get myself one
extra window here.
I don't know what people use for
multiplatform streaming.
Do I need an application? Can I not just
get something that hooks to OBS?
OBS is like the thing that I found is
the most stable across everything most
of the time.
I know Streamlabs is Well, maybe they
have a plugin. I know they do have like
a separate
version of OBS as well.
I want to at least get some stomach is
not good today.
Yep. I'll be right back.
I've been um trying to improve my
digestion for some athletics and
unfortunately that requires doing some
things that mess up first. So,
plugin for OBS.
Okay, I will try that.
Not right now, obviously. I'm going to
do this, but cool. Uh, okay. So,
I'm gonna put my headset on because the
freaking dog keeps barking. Actually,
you know what? Today's going to be
today's going to be
I know what Today is a good day for
my desktop audio muted. Cool. So, I'm
going to put some quiet music in the
background. So, I got dogs barking. I
got utter chaos here. And
we are going to get good work done
regardless.
get the YouTube chat.
So,
what I wanted to do here was check
what's in forward.
Cuz
I can't see anything else that would be
in here other than this. Can you?
I think it would be something like this.
Log prop
state.
Now, we're going to have to have a
little bit of a fancy setup to track all
this.
So the goal here is just to narrow down
where all these element wise ops are
coming from.
And uh then we'll write a kernel once we
know for sure.
What are you doing to improve? move. Um,
yeah. So, I've had basically just I've
had a million doctors and none of it's
worked. So, I'm trying some stuff from
the uh the gym where they actually coach
like serious athletes.
Um,
and there like there are a few different
things.
My case is a bit of a pain in the ass
though because I did a ton of damage to
mine like with all the caffeine studying
through college and then like several
bad cases of like really bad food
poisoning. So
yeah, I've been trying to fix it for a
long time. So I like at this point I'm
just like, "All right, we'll try a bunch
of stuff. We'll see."
Because otherwise like you go to doctors
and they just try to like they just show
pharmaceuticals at you. Like they'll
just try to like give you a modium or
whatever. was like, "Okay, cool. This
doesn't actually address the root
cause." Like, "Good job."
Siming
returns popular, but the Sim can't keep
up. Scientific Sim is really slow. Yeah,
that's their problem, man. We're going
to fix that.
This is the same thing with RL. RL
people said, "Oh yeah, the SIMs can't be
faster." And then I just made them
faster.
So yeah, it's not going to help a ton
right now on out of the box slows, but
this is a really good test bed for us to
improve the RL. We have been using it to
improve the RL. The algorithm is better
and more stable than it was before. We
have better understanding of the
algorithm now than we had before. The
next version will give us better
understanding than we have now. And
additionally, we're also going to make
the scientific sims faster.
Antibiotics.
Oh, yeah. Um, I don't really have
anything great, Jess. I've tried several
things. I don't know. I tried Brian
Johnson stuff for a bit. Sort of helped.
Tried AG1 for a bit. Sort of helps. Um,
actually the gym, they asked they
actually told me to try baking soda,
which is funny because usually that
messes up your digestion.
We're going to see whether that is the
thing that has me all messed up this
morning or not. It could be one of a
couple things. I have a couple different
probiotics to try as well. Um, also just
diet consistent has to be very
consistent for when I'm trying new
stuff.
They're quite a few things.
Okay. So, this is what we wanted here,
guys. Look. You see this? We just
What did we just do,
right? 16
is this element wise kernel. Okay, that
didn't help. Uh, vectorzed element wise
kernel that went down to nine.
Oh, we killed off a bunch of these
vectorized element wise kernel calls.
Look at this. This is plus 10% time
going into the uh the kernel
without this.
Okay, so this is
unrolled elementwise kernel was 6.4.
That didn't help. Reduce kernel.
Oh, the reduced kernel is gone.
Yeah, you see that the reduced kernel is
gone.
So let's label this.
This is
uh most of the vector
spots
reduce.
I want to like really isolate where the
hell everything's coming from though,
cuz we still have 22% element wise
kernel. You see this?
I'm actually going to give it
let's actually give this to Cloud real
Yep. Restroom again. This will be done
pretty soon though and we'll be able to
do Colonel D the rest of the day.
I'm going to let Claude take a quick
look um just to see if I get anything
that I have missed and then after that
I'm going to just like start looking for
ops myself.
You know, I wonder if it's because I
took the baking soda at the same time as
I took AG1.
Probably like probiotics plus
um
plus like alkaline is not good.
I don't know.
Huh?
Are you sure?
I don't think I have this in there.
Oh, well, yeah, we do have the encoder.
You're right. Cool.
Oh, did I miss? Hang on. It actually did
have something good here. So,
400 mil
Wait, no. Instances
119K mini groupoup calls
and then element wise calls will be
what's this? 60 + 90 150.
Okay.
Where'd you get 400k from?
260.
Yeah. Okay.
420.
Four sources above minus one. That might
fuse.
Oh, it really just is fuse everything.
Huh.
I want to try that real quick, which is
just take the um the biases out and just
see
I just want to see if this does it.
Right. We get rid of the decoder like
this.
Oh, the value function has one, too.
Is that really just not
built into the um the maple or the
kernel?
Does anybody know how important biases
actually are? Has anybody actually tried
in modern architectures?
Okay, let's see if this actually takes
ops off or not.
It'd be funny if this does.
I actually think that we're going to end
up using some of Peru's kernels. He
fused the value function. Um he he fused
like a couple of things
actually. Is there any reason not to
just fuse the value function and the um
the action output?
Well, yeah. I guess cuz then you'll do
split and you'll have like a cat
backwards.
Maybe not actually.
Maybe it won't.
It's different gradients.
Using Opus for real. Yeah. Look how I'm
using it though, dude. There no vibes
here. There's no vibe coding crap.
The first stream I did was absolutely
awful. I do not recommend that you do
that in any way whatsoever.
Yeah. No vibes. I mean, it's very
simple. It's just like you just have to
make a conscious decision as to whether
you want to outsource your thinking to
Claude or not.
If you outsource your thinking though,
you like don't deceive yourself into
thinking you have any value whatsoever
on top of the tool that you're using.
Like you either think and maintain
control or you don't.
Uh I do not see a meaningful difference
here. Anybody
see meaningful difference?
No, they're all basically the same,
right?
I mean, it's actually a good thing if
torch has biases optimized, which it
should. It really should.
What does it What is it running?
Oh, I see.
What is that supposed to do?
Like you can run that. What is that
supposed to do?
Fuse bias edition.
beta parameter.
You can run that, but I don't think it's
going to do anything.
Oh, I see. It's running the profiler.
Yeah, you can do that. That's fine.
[sighs]
G. Oh, if multiple ops, that'd be really
bad.
Uh, yeah, you can run that. I It doesn't
really need to be doing this, but that's
fine.
Well, that means we get our biases back,
which is nice.
Oh, I see what it's just trying to
figure out what things are ops and what
things aren't ops. I rest from yet
again. I'll be right back and then we
will figure out essentially we just have
to figure out where all the element wise
ops are coming from and then we will be
solid.
>> Okay.
Kublast doesn't fuse activations. What?
Kublast does not fuse activations.
Um,
where did you get that from?
Oh, activations. Yeah, that's G. It
doesn't fuse the G unless you have an
epilog, right?
Hang on. What? Huh? Why can't I type?
Yo, I can't type. What?
Oh, come on. We're going to do this now.
Really?
Let me go check my cluster. This is what
I get for deving on a cluster.
If I were just there in person, that'd
be a lot easier.
Uh what's it called?
I'm going call it.
I mean, I really like I honestly think
that the optimal workflow Oops. Come on
camera. The optimal workflow is to just
have two desktops. have yourself like a
normal desktop that you do your work on
and then have one right next to it that
you have uh you know you have plugged in
access to wired access to uh but you
don't have monitors plugged in or like
you know desktop apps on or anything.
Oh, everything is freaking down
at 1010.
Lovely.
You don't need an H200. No, dude.
A 5090 desktop will do it. You can buy
one for like six, seven grand,
not like 40.
I actually
it can't be a power outage though
because we have backup power. It must be
an internet outage.
That's some [ __ ]
Well, that totally screws up my work.
That completely screws up my work. Um,
what do I do about this?
I can set it up locally,
but I can't run this stuff locally.
It'll screw up the stream.
I can get a dash box, I guess, but I
don't really want to set that up.
Uh, okay,
great.
I guess I have to get this set up
locally now.
That's like such [ __ ]
Man, everything just go wrong today.
Holy [ __ ] Morning.
And everything goes wrong this morning.
Actually, I think NSIS won't break won't
screw up my uh stream. I think only NRO
screws it up. Or NCU.
Oh, come on. We're going to fail on CUDA
macros.
I have a lot on here. I do
like PI usage. Cool.
Nvidia Jetson board.
I don't know.
For RL, I just recommend people get good
desktops. That's it.
We have Oh, do we not have food at all?
I'm going to just go keep checking
whether my machines are back up. That's
some [ __ ]
That can only be internet outage, I
would assume,
cuz they're all down.
Yeah, they're literally all down.
Detected CUDA version 12.
How is this the detected?
I probably have the wrong link.
I probably installed like food toolkit
or something.
Okay, we'll just get ourselves a nice
like little CUDA 13 local install, I
guess.
Dude, I Why does this [ __ ] happen? This
is why you always use Docker containers,
by the way.
This is why you always use Dockers.
There's always just some dumb packaging
[ __ ] It's like, "Oh, you can just
like, you know, you just learn it and
it's No, it just nothing ever makes
sense
every freaking time. I swear.
And stuff still doesn't make any damn
sense.
packaging installs just mess up
constantly.
Uh, the cluster went offline apparently.
I think there's an internet outage, so I
can't do much. I'm trying to set it up
locally, but I don't actually have a
good local setup at the moment. So, I'm
going to try to get something set up
locally so I can at least like do some
profiling, but I'm not going to be able
to see if something's 10 mil or not.
We'll get the local setup anyways
though.
Luckily, I did push everything relevant
PRs. I could, but I'm supposed to have
10 mil today. We're starting a bunch of
new client stuff this week, most likely.
And I'd really, really like to be able
to tell the new clients that we've got
10 mil in dev.
I said I'd review PRs, but I want to at
least hit the damn 10 mil, you know, cuz
like once I hit the 10 mil, then pretty
much everything else is just clean up.
Until I hit the 10 mil, it's like
there's still outgoing like things to be
discovered.
Brainfall.
dude. What?
How does training just like break
everything like this? This is completely
like a hangman.
Oops.
I don't understand.
Yeah, this is why you use Docker. See
this? If I'm having trouble with this,
this is not Humber, by the way. Like,
this is Torch and Cuda. Okay, this is
nothing of puffer.
Lovely.
This work?
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, we have something.
It's half speed because we're on a
uh half price hardware,
but it's actually still faster than
Puffer 3 on the budget hardware.
Okay,
Next.
I'm going to run a couple myself first.
This is a 57D just
I just copy. I just do this on
everything. Yeah.
Oh, come on. I don't have the end probe
script. Uh,
I thought that I committed that, man.
>> [sighs and snorts]
>> Now I don't remember the oneliner.
Oh, of course. Right when I get this set
all set up, the internet comes back on
on the other boxes. Lovely.
Of course.
just waste my time.
Hell of a morning.
Uh I have not been paying attention to
the YouTube chat uh because I have not
been showing up properly.
That's fine. Everybody moved over.
Anyways,
are we back? No, I can see you. Oh,
actually now it does work. it randomly
started working on YouTube again. So, I
think that the uh the theme of this
morning has every has been everything
randomly breaks for no reason and then
everything randomly fixes itself without
me doing anything. Cool.
Let's hope this is stable for the rest
of the day. I can't really do much if it
isn't.
Come on,
stupid hotkeys.
All right.
I'm going to commit this before I forget
it.
Come on.
What the heck is wrong today with this
thing?
One of these days everything is just
going to work.
There's not much to commit actually.
It's really just I need access to the
hardware.
Just
uh Okay, let's go to
Jarvis.
I don't want Jarvis, man. My main form
factor.
I want basically, you know, if I want if
I were to actually build um like an
assistant, it would be kind of like this
except that it would uh it would not be
put in this format that takes you out of
your coding.
It would just be the little puffer fish
that sits up here puffing and spits out
a speech bubble with stuff every so
often and is actively just watching you
as you're coding. It's preventing you
from like doing dumb [ __ ] and like
adding like non-distracting fixes in
real time without breaking your train of
thought and then also takes voice input
and then uh text output. That would be
great.
I actually don't hate the models
anymore. I really don't hate the models.
I mostly just hate the people developing
them and their view of the world.
course I know Clippy dude. I'm not a
zoomer.
Well, once you're 29, that means you've
got one year left to be um
fitter in every possible way than you
were when you were
That's how I see it.
Me at 30 is going to kick the [ __ ] out
of me at 20 in every possible way.
been in pretty good shape at 20. I was
in Let me think.
I had not worked out in a bit, but I
just stopped working out cuz I got to
college.
My best from that. I think when I was
like when I stopped playing squash, my
best was a 14-minute two-mile, which I
can do now despite being heavier.
15 pull-ups. I can do maybe 12 now, but
I'm also way heavier. I could barely
bench a plate. Now I rep two plates, no
problem. Bunch of other stuff,
so I'm doing all right.
Gen Z, I nope, I do not claim any
affiliation with Gen Z. I identify as
the boomer. Thank you very much.
Yeah, I'm in Florida.
Don't want to be a boomer.
I don't know. I definitely have the get
off my lawn tendencies.
element wise.
Yeah, we got two ops
per layer. It would be
it's two ops per layer.
type conversion before replay? It could
be that
It should already be in this case low
32, right?
I feel like way sharper today for some
reason.
AI fix.
Dude, I just just ignore Twitter. People
are so [ __ ] dumb. Just ignore
Twitter.
Like,
it will actually drive you nuts. I felt
so much better because of all things, I
spent the hour that I would be spending
like scrolling X playing Runescape.
That's the standard.
[laughter]
That chest environment is going to be
awesome when it's done.
Like the thing is most people actually
don't care about progress or truth in
any real sense. They just care about
whatever stupid narrative makes them
feel better.
So like why bother listening to them?
How did I mess up the default encoder?
I must have just missed something right
while I was editing.
Then in that case, I can do forward
You playing.
I'm going to try to just like post more
high quality material on Twitter this
year and spend less time just scrolling
it. We'll see whether that's actually a
good strategy for growth or whatever,
but it's going to be a way better
strategy for having my mind clear to do
work.
five coding ones.
I mean like I'm just translating that in
my head. It's okay if somebody doesn't
like thinking or doesn't like not
thinking and wants to think, but I
believe not thinking will remain and
continue to evolve.
I think the thing that is missed here is
programming is just about the damn
closest thing we have to pure logic.
like okay yes mathematics but it's very
abstract
programming is very very precise and
concrete
um you do not need to be a genius to get
into quite a lot of programming
um but it's very very much clear
thinking
way more so than writing
writing is too fuzzy
I actually don't understand.
Oh, I know what happened.
There we go.
What do we have here?
Exactly two pretty much. Yeah, exactly
two
per layer. You see this?
Certainly nothing should be an
elementwise opt
We'll try this.
Where's graph valuecopy?
I highly doubt this. Oh, I guess
actually
that'd be interesting if copy show up as
these element wise ops. I'd be pretty
surprised about that.
Is it going with opus? I mean, it's just
normal work now at this point. SD
I'm using it sometimes for some things
and I'm not using it for other things.
quality Twitter cont will help
crash out more on stream.
And I don't want to just be the dude
that rants at everything. It just [ __ ]
pisses me off.
Like I hope stuff doesn't just piss me
off forever. I just like we build better
stuff.
we actually decide to use brains and
then I don't need to be pissed off
anymore.
But I don't give a [ __ ] what they're
launching.
They're a bunch of bastards anyways. I
don't care.
Okay. At the very least, right?
Yeah, that didn't do it. Cool.
We're going to comment out the entire
freaking loop and we're going to see
what happens. All right.
Where?
Let's see if they're in the copy.
This stuff actually matters. Like this
is half of our perf
on eval.
Okay, that is 23 million SPS eval on a
5070.
So, yeah, we still got overhead.
We could very well hit 50 mil eval SPS
um on a 5090.
Yes. One for two
beginner and RL start RL from zero. What
would you learn first? What's one small
project? Jerry, I have a perfect article
for you. So, I get this question all the
time and I put together free high
quality resources for just that.
here. Follow this. This will take you
through the process of building um
like multiple projects. I actually would
suggest you do something if you're new
that is way less time than one week.
Like do something you can do in one
evening and then do something you can do
in a few days. And if you're still on
board after that, try something more
ambitious. It'll take you through
everything though.
Oh yeah, and for folks watching, um, we
are almost at 5K stars. So if you want
to help me for absolutely free, just
feed this puffer a star on GitHub. Thank
you.
That'll be useful for me, too. Yep. I
have multiple of those articles.
I do produce a fair bit of educational
content.
Oh, okay.
Zero.
Is this actually this call 13% right
here? If this call is 13% of the time,
I'm going to lose my fit.
I'm actually just going to lose my fit.
If this is 13% of the time is that one
zero call.
per roll for Oh, yeah. But this wouldn't
be it, right?
No, that wouldn't be it.
What if RL were just fast guys? Huh?
What about that?
Now we still got 13.8.
That actually doesn't make zero show up
at all. That's like completely wrong.
Actually, I can figure this out. I It's
not going to be able to guess. Yeah, I
can totally Here.
I know how we're going to do this. It's
very easy for me to narrow this down.
It's just going to take a few minutes
here. Let's just get me another window.
I wish they'd not show up in the
background like that. That'd be really
nice.
The Abuntu windowing system is such a
pain in the ass. All right,
first thing we're going to do,
we're going to go to roll out
play
like this. We're going to comment the
whole function.
Well, sounds I'm on um Twitch, YouTube,
and X, so it's annoying.
And I don't want to keep like delaying
this release forever, but at the same
time, we're so close to having this
thing, the Perf target, and I'm so close
to having something I am like truly
proud of,
you know?
Okay.
Element wise kernel 49,000 instances of
element wise kernel
61k. Okay, there's still a bunch of
element wise kernels getting freaking
fall.
Any other [ __ ] in this wrapper?
No. There's nothing here. Nothing
possible. Right.
It's got to be in this function.
I mean there really we should not have
to have any calls other than
we should have some copy calls and we
should have two kernels.
One's a maple.
The other is the gate.
Ooh. 161 mil. Well, okay. Yeah, duh. Cuz
we got to run the end.
Okay. Yeah, same thing. There's some
variability. Same. But yeah, not in the
end.
Not the end, guys.
I still do not understand where this
[ __ ] is coming from.
does not contain Cuda kernel data.
That's what we want, right?
There's a copy there, a copy there.
There's a narrow call.
Is it the narrow kernel?
But that's not a kernel, dude. That's a
slice.
Profiling the for pass. We're trying to
eliminate like stupid uh redundant
kernels.
Welcome.
The hell's this?
Actually, I want to see. So this should
be no kernels, right?
Oh, you dumb. I just reran it, but
whatever. I'm done. No worries.
Wrong command is quick. So, if this
fails because there are no kernels,
that's a good thing.
What do I think about AI safety?
I think it's a legitimate topic that's
discussed in often the stupidest way
possible by the most out of touch people
possible.
Many of them are actively just trying to
con you.
Okay, look at this.
So
this 24 mil here we're this is pure end
bandwidth here. This is pure endbound.
So, we'll like find some better end
settings or whatever.
And this can get even faster
cuz I think breakout will go way faster
than this.
But presumably, we can get this even
faster than um what we're seeing here.
Okay, that is way better.
74%.
once per four forwards.
Uh that would be the
you know what that is?
Okay. So, this is actually fine.
I know what it is.
This is not me testing a kernel. This is
me testing everything at once. Here,
That's insane
that it does it that way.
Well, now we know. So, because it's a
size one output, it's doing something
stupid.
Come on. You can't tell that's dead
code.
>> This is actually the uh the kernel that
um
wrote was to do this.
I shouldn't have had the force export.
Takes forever. Okay, look at this folks.
Look at this.
We have the entire forward pass
of this network
down to two
different line items. We got kernel 2,
which is matt moles, and we got our
gate.
God damn it.
Okay, I'm going to get myself a nice mug
of tea to hopefully settle my stomach.
It's mostly better, but I could use some
tea. And then what we're going to do is
we're going to figure out all those
other stupid things that we were doing.
We're going to figure out how to either
fuse them into the existing kernel or to
put them into their own very fast kernel
together in as few ops as possible.
Sound good?
Because otherwise this is ridiculous.
We should not be having kernel
operations
for all of this mess.
But that does look nice.
This is the goal for puffer, right? We
end up with like this super clean
profile. We know exactly where we're
spending all of our compute and we will
be good. And if boy can do this, the
really cool thing about this is let's
say that we are actually able to track
where every little bit of computers
coming accurately in Puffer and we get
like our 10 mil, then I'm going to be
able to open it up to you guys and put
bounties on Perf improvements.
That sound pretty cool, right?
Cuz I'm not a great kernel dev. Probably
a lot of the kernels that we write can
be made much faster. I mean, this is 21%
time being spent on gates right here.
Admittedly, this is probably pretty
close to just min kernel launch time,
but I don't know, maybe we can fuse both
of these two together. Who knows? Maybe
you can write a custom log. I don't
know. I'll be right back.
All right.
Okay.
We start uncommenting stuff. We see
where stupid kernels come back. Yeah.
The reward buffer copy thing is quite
easy.
Like we can always move that to the end
or whatever we want, right?
Okay, look at that.
We add back in a bunch of elementwise
kernel and a bunch of unrolled
elementwise kernel.
to have to do some stuff with these
types
runs. Uh, this probably messes some
stuff up,
but I think for the purpose of profile
Stupid thing should not be launching a
bunch of kernels.
Okay,
it's still there.
Does C have a long wait? C have a long
float?
It does, right?
Double. Duh. Idiot.
This is a tiny amount of bandwidth
increase
and saves us from having to deal with a
kernel,
two kernels actually.
Yes, you do need to change this. I
forgot about that.
Not have not released the essay yet,
man. It's just going to be a blog post.
I have to write it. I've been doing a
million things
there. I will write it. Like I said,
and just use it to change these types
real quick. I could technically have it
change the um
the end type.
Honestly, double would just be easier,
right?
Feel like it. It's still part of the
test. No, it does improve workflow, but
only for certain things. So, you will
see like I didn't use it at all
yesterday for um environment
development,
right? But because I have I have here CN
code, I've got pi bind, I've got um this
like CUDA vectorization code, I've got
torch lib, um I've got kernels, I've got
a billion different things and I
essentially need something to like a lot
of the things are just refactoring. It's
fuzzy refactors.
I think this is sketch. We'll just done
here.
We'll let it for now, but I think it's
going to have to change it.
See, like what am I doing here? It's
going to look like I'm taking a ton of
edits from here, but this is literally
just refactoring um like two types of
variables. And there's just there's a
lot of repeated crap, right? There's a
lot of repeated crap.
And normally I put a lot of effort into
making things not crap like this, but
for now I'm sort of stuck with a lot of
things being duplicated.
At least for now.
And hopefully if nothing's broken here,
this should then cut out a couple of
CUDA a couple of CUDA kernels for the
type casts.
findingh. Yep.
It's a double char.
The observations are still going to be a
pain.
This here is literally a um I'm
refactoring two variables to have
different types.
So
I think doing fuzzy variable re uh
variable type refactor
is quite fine. Yes.
Got this.
What do we think about
Wait, beckon. It should not This should
not be getting cold.
Uh cuz this did not get passed actually.
You see? So this is actually dated.
That's fine.
right. So, these actually should be
okay.
At the very least, we should be able to
have these fine. There is
one cast we can avoid,
but only one.
Okay. Okay. Well, we got rid of the
unrolled element wise kernel.
Let's see where the element wise kernel
comes from.
See which of these D types mismatch.
Yeah.
Uh, excuse me.
This is not supposed to match if um
activity buffer request lazy function
loading.
Ah, look. CUDA launch kernel. You see
that
CUDA launch kernel element wise
[ __ ] is what that is. That is
[ __ ]
Screw you, torch.
I do a freaking copy operation and it's
launching kernels behind the hood.
What's going on with that?
I think it can probably handle our
buffers, right?
buffers.
Time to switch to sklearn. That
statement makes [ __ ] all sense, man.
actually. Is it not? Am I dumb here or
is it just horizon segment input?
Does that not work?
Wait. Horizon
The thing is we're going to have to swap
it.
It's actually quite thorough, which is
nice.
Yeah. See, this is just This is good.
It's just going to have to swap all the
dimensions.
This is definitely the right call for
eval though. Like the RL eval loop is
always going to be this way.
It's kind of funny because
like Claude gets dramatically more
useful the worse your code base is.
And this one is like this is probably
the chunk now of code that it's just the
most unavoidably pain in the ass.
No.
No, you're not going to do this.
stride copy really bad.
See, I figured that there would be like
some sort of um who to transfer option
for strided copy, but there just isn't.
That's funny.
I think we killed off the overhead,
guys.
3.4% unrolled element wise
smaller.
Where's it coming from?
I'm just going to continue to sit here
until we figure it all out.
This should definitely help us. I don't
know if this is enough for 10 mil. I
mean, keep in mind we haven't written
like
this is still minimized. It's going to
take us a couple hours before we have
something even remotely able to train
again after all this changes.
But this is what you have to do. You
have to shred everything and then you
have to re put it back together.
So now we get to see whether I still
have um
element wise.
We have one element wise kernel per
h
per map.
Eh,
that's weird.
Oh, no. This is the wrong one.
That's the wrong one. Right.
Let's just do this.
Hang on. I have to be so careful with
this. I like keep messing stuff up. Make
sure you get your data correct.
I want to see how many calls there are.
We can tell by this what it'll be.
Do we accept 3% overhead for no reason?
No. No, we don't.
I bet I can port the clamp into the um
advantage kernel if I have to.
Okay. So now we have now we actually can
tell
um here
Okay, basically this one element wise
per board pass
Oh, actually, is that the unavoidable
one?
Oh, maybe not.
Is it just fine?
Yeah, it is just fine.
That's just my straight mess up.
It should be float 64.
Okay, cool. There is still going to be
one unavoidable one, but it's not there.
Now we understand this try to copy
[ __ ] right?
Thank you for reminding me. Actually, I
meant to message him.
Yes. Okay, there we go. Look, this now
has zero kernels.
Zero kernels. None. Not up. on.
Uh we can take the buff states,
right? These buffer states,
we're good with these, right?
And zero should be not a kernel call,
right?
If zero is a kernel call, that's screwed
up.
That's not good.
What the heck is this?
Is it? Wait, is it one?
No, it's two.
probably one of these is not contiguous,
right?
I'm liking it for this thing I'm doing
right here.
That's funny. This is all garbage. All
garbage feed.
The only cool thing on this entire feed
is the Hightail early access. That's the
only cool thing in the entire feed
today.
Wait, hang on. Block size.
Wait, num layers.
What is something you'd like people to
do with popular lib if they haven't
already? Honestly, we just like there's
a ton of core research, but then I want
like more medium complex MS and more
medium complexity applications.
The thing is if I give that to new users
like
it's not straightforward yet. You
actually still really need to know quite
a bit to get medium complexity stuff to
work. Uh that will change. It will
become easier.
But yeah, that's probably the main the
main thing. We have a lot of uh
contributors that can do like relatively
simple MS and like kind of start to get
a little bit more interesting. And we do
have a couple like good ones in PR as
well. Um, but like just cranking up the
end complexity in general is pretty
tough.
No, it'll get easier with more info.
Okay.
Everything got to be contiguous.
Uh there will be one unavoidable
one unavoidable kernel I believe. Maybe
two.
Yeah. So, I just I basically just had um
I had all the indexing wrong or not
wrong. I had the indexing backwards for
contiguous.
I had it contiguous for train, but it's
better to have everything be contiguous
for eval.
This 14% elementwise overhead for
[ __ ] is ridiculous.
Like you see it's not even a lot of
time. This is five microsconds, right?
But like when everything is this fast,
stuff just adds up.
Buffer really fast.
didn't update some checks. Super basic
check.
That's good.
See if there anything else.
I think that's probably the only one.
Unless there's one forward train.
Yeah, there's forward train expected.
We'll have to adjust as well for this.
But um
this is a good progress.
Messages not being received on YouTube.
Debug check. Yep, there your messages.
Boink.
They're there.
Okay, that's fine.
Yeah, that's fine. We can do this
transpose weirdness.
I mean, I'd very much like uh you know,
cast fireball definition of AI. I like
that one.
It's probably in my backlog, man. Is it
the overcooked one or is it What is it?
I do review stuff. It just takes me
quite a while.
You should keep reminding me, though.
All right. There's a tic-tac-toe end.
Oh, the nonogram puzzle. Okay, that
one's nice.
I remember you telling me this one.
Cool. This is nice. Actually, this is a
very good end. I remember this one. I
like this one. Yeah, this is a very good
end.
I'm backlogged on PRs though, right now,
man. I'm going to have to take some time
to review some, but like it's What can I
tell you? I'm grinding the heck out of
Puffer 4.
Yeah, that would count as a medium bas
unless you trolled and like I can
actually solve it way faster. If it's
taking like billions of steps and still
making progress, then that's a medium.
You can do that fine. It's just messing
with um the storage layout for train.
We're going to redo that anyways.
We really just need the eval layout to
be good right now. No, it's NP hard.
That's funny.
No, no, I know you're not like trolling
on that. I'm like, oh, I see. Well,
I don't know. Is it possible? Are there
any NP hard problems that are known to
have like really easy approximate
solutions?
Like it's possible to define classes of
problems that are NP hard where subsets
of them are really easy,
you know,
to obliterate it. Oh, we're working on a
puffer.
I think actually what I'm doing right
now in particular is going to be so good
for little networks.
People are going to be able to train
super fast on their laptops with this.
Assuming you have well, you will need an
an Nvidia GPU of any variety. So that is
the uh requirement.
Maybe you won't eventually though. You
know, we'll see. I could always write a
CPU version of these.
reset in solvable.
Not average. Yeah. Let me use the
restroom real quick. Be right back.
Let's see.
Select.
No.
What bot is that? What?
Oh, hang on. Is Puffer live helpful in
optimizing environments that are
entirely GPU accelerated? Yes, because
then you're going to get bound by
everything else.
Like all the other libraries are slow.
Though honestly, most GPU accelerated
environments that people show me are
actually slow as well.
Isn't that just not
be at num layers?
Wait.
Uh,
am I dumber or is this false?
Take
all layers.
Oh
wait, what if we do B?
Oh wait, what if we do B? Okay.
Still big matter. Things things are
improving, Jess. Things are improving
quite rapidly.
It's just a whole bunch of making sure
memor is contiguous.
I'm surprised Cuda doesn't have like
cuda strided copy.
There is cudam copy 2D. So this thing
exists which is just stupid.
So the point of doing this now is we
have um initial state per
uh where is it?
Yeah, initial state is going to be per
buffer.
Uh and then that should not have any
problems with continuity anymore.
optimization to be done and they could
decide. Yeah. You see, and it actually
matters a ton.
Context usage
getting dumber by the prompt. That
doesn't make any sense, dude.
Well, good thing I'm not asking it to do
anything hard then.
But I still I don't think that the thing
you said makes sense.
I think only if you cross like like if
you compact the context that can mess
things up. Just having long for context
shouldn't
Okay. What do we have here?
Layers.
Yeah, this just a reversion. That's
fine.
So, it's going to have to be vector like
this.
That might actually screw up the um
that shouldn't screw anything up.
It will be like this per buffer
initialization.
And I think that's pretty much it. So
then we should see uh no more
state compacting
or state contiguous ridiculous kernel
overhead for no reason.
It's actually clean because now you
don't have to even narrow or anything
like that. It's just the index.
We'll see whether this is um
extra kernels or not.
We're pretty much just trying to figure
out all the redundant places this thing
is launching
extra kernels.
And then we graph everything that's um
remaining.
Oh, beautiful.
Absolutely beautiful. Look at that.
All right. Um, this graph ops here
You can go like this
if this works. This is the entire
forward loop except for the zero ops in
the clamp.
just make sure that the ops copy is not
messing us up
and then we will uh
we'll start rebuilding the rest from
here.
some stuff that needs some commenting,
yada yada.
Now, let's just take it nice and slow.
We'll finish this one. Go through the
rest of the net. Good.
So I think then if this works we will
see if we can get this to train
and then we'll start on the backward
pass.
That one will be substantially harder.
breaking into tech,
probably not the best person to ask.
If you're looking to learn stuff in this
area, I have plenty of material. But if
you're looking for conventional career
advice, not the guy for you.
Okay, this is the entire forward pass.
All the only thing we cut out was the
zeroing.
We definitely can go do um where we do
it
state out.
And then that'll be everything except
the state zeroing and the reward
clamping. I don't think I commented
anything else. We can always try to put
the Oh, yeah, the Gallup. Yeah, there's
still the Gallup. All right. All right.
Well, there's still a few small things
then.
and refuse it.
I would like to have that fused
Oh yeah, obviously they're they're
actually there are a lot of commented
opts,
but we know which ones they are.
This is not going to be the real number
because it's not doing um
there's some options omitting
at 9.6 9.7.
So we have to do a few of these
operations.
Oops.
because of pretty much all the extra
overhead, right?
and now it actually kind of trains even
though I don't have reward clamping in.
And it's still faster than before.
It's still 9.5 mil.
Not bad.
Not bad at all.
Now, of course, what we can do is we can
go back and profile this,
right?
Let's see what the profile looks like
now.
Oh, this is the profile for everything.
So, obviously this is going to contain a
ton of crap.
I'm curious though. We'll see how much
wiz got rid
You'll see peruse. Um,
where's this like RL plays?
They're not checking on this one.
I'm find
sample logs here. I want this one
probably.
Okay.
Well, look at that. We are now up to
45%.
In matt moles.
And look at that. The next two lines are
their kernel. That's good.
Uh we still have this reduce operation
here.
and this vectorzed element was 16 20
22. This is still better than before.
Now we've got more of our real stuff up
top.
Let's go check eval overhead though.
That's what I meant to do originally
Uh, I can definitely tell there's a
perfect to this
from sampling.
Let's go see if we can find this
colonel.
Okay, this is what we want, right? Right
here.
Hard code based on this is not amazing.
strides. H
interesting.
Okay. You know, you know what we'll do?
Let's let's check this first.
Yeah, look at this. So, we have
you see this
huge amount of overhead.
I'm going just have to put this to be
non- templatized
Oh, we need to uh let's auto this
compact as first
cuz what we're going to have it do is
we're going to hit it to port.
I think I can probably
This might be giving too much to um
Is this going to be giving too much to I
don't forward call?
Actually, I don't think it is because
forward call this is Yeah, this is only
This doesn't need grabs.
Yeah, this doesn't need grabs at all. So
this is it has a a very simple way to do
this then
it's fine.
So, actually, this is a good this is a
good point for me to just go grab a mug
of tea. And then what we're going to do
is we're going to get uh with we're
going to basically get to get this thing
to port peruse kernel exactly as uh the
rest of our code is set up. And then
we'll be able to time this as a third
line.
And then that actually should give us a
little perf bump as well. I'll be right
back though.
Okay.
Got teeth.
Did I miss him explaining context? Not
really.
We are um
we are optimizing the crap out of the
overhead
in the evaluation loop at the moment.
We've got it down to except for this
here
these ops is two kernels. It's literally
the matl
and uh the gate kernel. And because of
that we've done like a 2x reduction in
overhead which is a 5% increase to
training speed. But it's actually going
to be a double increase like 2x increase
to per for some applications which is
why I'm spending so much time on this.
You know 10 mil is not just 10 mil. It's
representative of a lot more.
a dance or something.
Would you prefer I watch you on Twitter
or Twitter here?
You just wherever is your favorite
platform.
It doesn't really matter honestly.
okay. Okay. So, what we're going to do
here Yeah. Right.
Okay, so this looks like a huge amount
of stuff. Um, but it's basically a huge
amount of stuff because everything's
duplicated in five places.
No MCPS. The hell's no
um feels more important? Yeah, Twitter
is Game Boy Super. No idea.
Not another just a normal stream. Man,
I'm using it like the way I normally use
it for basic stuff. Um, this admittedly
this is the probably the heaviest thing
I've used it for all day, but this is
basically like
so the way that this works, I guess I
can explain why this is fine the way it
is.
So, we have several kernels. Okay. And
those kernels, they're defined in
kernels.cu.
They have launch functions functions
that all look the same. They have
bindings to torque in modules.cu.
Um then they have to be defined and
exported in puffer.cpp,
right? And they have to be added um like
to graphing and kernel ops with flags.
Okay.
Yeah. Okay. That's the initial port.
They have to be added to that with
flags. And then they have to be added to
because I have not consolidated yet.
they have to be added to both test
microbench which is the python version
and then profile kernel cu which is the
pure cuda version uh with graphing
support and a bunch of other stuff. So
it's just like everything is duplicated
like six times and the actual amount of
like new logic that is required here is
almost nothing.
So it looks like oh look at this massive
amount of code from claw but the thing
is like look at what this is writing.
Okay so first of all it didn't write
this this is a direct port of existing
code
and then this is uh matching our exact
syntax or our exact style for our other
kernels like this is this is all our
structure. This is how we have our stuff
done. Uh and this is no logic. This is
just calling a launch.
uh this is literally just like grabbing
these lines out and pulling them into a
function. So like if you just look at
the actual thing added, this is not
actually
writing anything new, right? And the
thing is normally I just don't have code
projects that are this redundant, right?
Because it sucks when you have this much
redundant code. But because I have
custom kernels and I have torch lib and
I have Python binds and I have all this
stuff going on, it's kind of
unavoidable.
So in this specific case, plot is very
helpful because of the amount of
redundancy. But you know, if I'm writing
a new environment or if I'm doing other
stuff, it's dramatically less helpful.
You know, not zero, but certainly way
less helpful.
It's really more so like to port Jess.
It's a port but with like very clear
existing structure for everything.
Like the reason I'm happy with it
writing this much code is because I'm
confident that it's going to produce
pretty much the exact same thing I would
have written uh manually with the
guidance I've given it.
Did Peruse kernel have random logics in
here?
I'm not asking it to do that much stuff
at once. where it needs that
like this looks like a lot of code but
again this is directly matching other
code that I've written myself
what I'm pretty much asking it to do is
apply a template if that makes sense
Okay, I'll let it do it this for now.
This fine. Sure.
See, like this test here. I The only
reason I take this because this is dumb
is that I know this is getting thrown
away.
Like I know that that's getting thrown
769 on Twitter.
It's cumulative. Jess,
some of the streams have like 10k plus.
This is kind of just like your normal
chill dev stream
where we're doing something that's a
little bit more technical.
So, it's not going to be as interesting
to watch as me ranting at whatever the
hell. But, um, this is ultimately how
puffer is made
and this is how we make the
breakthroughs.
I had Runescape level fun doing it. If
you have fun and you're learning stuff,
then do it, dude.
Don't worry about like,
okay, yes, you have to make sure that
you are able to actually get jobs and
things that you need yet. But like the
most important thing longer term is that
you are enjoying learning stuff and
you'll be able to do more of it
and you're getting better constantly.
look at that guys.
Now, it does say it's fast in the graph
version, funny enough.
No, very possibly. Uh, this won't be a
huge deal
with the graphing, but it exists.
because I saw it go down.
Really?
That doesn't make any sense because
there's no way I've ever had like 14k
live and I've seen that before.
I'm pretty sure it's cumulative
Like,
it is very good.
Looks much better when used in the sort
of more restricted capacity that I'm
using it in.
You got first place grand prize. Oh,
dude. Congrats
UCSD. Yeah, congrats man. I know um I
know one guy from there. Is it UCSD?
What was it?
And so this is just going to go here
and then we will see
if that gets down to one additional
kernel call.
Thank your brother an inspiration
jumping into coding was deciding if I
was going to go to grad school. Hey, I'm
happy I can help, man. It's mostly just
like, you know, learn about things that
you're interested in. Build stuff that's
awesome. Do what you need to do in order
to make things work financially.
Um, and then don't pay too much
attention to all the people that are
like very proud to not be thinking about
things, right?
Yes. So, there's this weirdness with
RNG.
Okay. So, we're going to do now, we're
going to see what this profile looks
like with
the uh the new custom kernel. And all
credit goes to Peru for this one, right?
Let's see what line numbers we get or
line items we get.
this. The wrong one. Don't worry. This
is not the right one. That's too many
things.
That actually doesn't make any sense to
me at all.
Oh, you know what? I bet this is all
from Rand.
Yeah, that's what I'm trying to figure
cuz it needs noise.
But I don't know if it needs to be done
this way.
cool rand.
See, this is this is what I would expect
as well. You would just do it inside of
the kernel itself.
So, you see what it is. It's basically
just like, hey, torch is doing whatever
it's doing with this crazy RAM. What if
we just do it in the kernel?
I actually don't know if that's going to
be better or not
because I actually know how RNG sampling
works on uh CUDA
like on CPU it would totally make sense
what I'm doing here
Okay, this sampling thing might be a
little scary. I'm going to let it try
this at least first to see if it fixes
the profile and then we'll look at it.
Build interactive voice first podcast
platform. Use voice commands like hey
host
paint on previous podcast from host
clone the voice combo get saved to
another tab
really good UIX
trained you trained it on previous
podcasts.
How on earth did you train it on
previous podcast from the host?
Everything else in there is like what I
would expect from um a good hackathon
project.
Do you actually set up fine-tuning
language model fine-tuning or something
on the transcript in two days or
whatever it was?
You said train it on previous podcasts.
So I presumably that's transcripts.
Yeah.
ability to entropy. There very well
might be just
we just need some experiments on it.
Yeah. So, all it's doing is moving our
GEN into the kernel.
Again, I actually don't have any idea
whether this will be efficient.
Yeah. So, it doesn't need the RNG
anymore.
Oh, I see. Well, that's not going to get
traced, you dummy.
So that's going to break training right
now because the the um
this is Claude not being smart enough to
know how cudgraphs work,
but I mostly want to see the uh the line
profile from this
That's an easy fix though. We'll just
move the RNG gen outside of the uh for
P.
Yeah. Okay. You can do what you want
with the uh the shitty Python file.
That's fine. That's getting deleted
anyways.
I mean, pretty much all we want is we
just want the one line for this.
Like there's just no other way to
optimize this if um is going to be
lame system prompt transcripts
embed previous vectors search. Oh, I
launch platform through embeddings
compute for that but failed and scrap in
the last few hours.
Yeah, it's a whole bunch of stuff to be
gluing together.
One thing I'd encourage you to try try
to do, Quinn. So, they're like there are
two different types of projects you can
sort of do, right? Like you'll notice
that a lot of the stuff I'm doing here,
even as a very experienced step, it's
very slow, right?
A very small amount actually changes
from day to day. even on a very
productive day. And this is because when
you're gluing together a lot of existing
things, you know, progress can feel very
fast. Um, when you're doing something
that's kind of different and hasn't
really been done before,
um, and is not using like large reusable
components, things get a lot slower, but
you're going to learn something that's
very fundamentally different. So, both
types of projects are good to do. You'll
get experience from both. I'd encourage
you to give them both a try for sure.
you know, definitely don't just glue
stuff together.
That said, that sounds like a pretty big
thing that you were able to get working
quite quickly. And uh congrats on the
win.
Okay. Um,
that's funky.
So,
that is actually apparently faster.
Cool.
It depends, Quinn. For a hackathon, what
I just told you is very bad advice,
right? Because it's going to be much
slower.
But if you're trying to like understand
something, you know, trying to build
something that's sort of out there and
learn like lower level stuff or, you
know, learn in like a specific domain,
you know, you want to go wide sometimes,
but you also want to go deep sometimes.
How's Claude today?
I don't know it exists.
Thank.
As you can see, I'm still writing a
bunch of code. I'm still doing a bunch
of work.
It's a nice tool.
It is a nice tool.
Oops.
Oh, yeah. Go ahead and run that. That's
for you.
Like I've had to learn so much in the
process of building Puffer 4.
Like think about it. I'd written one
kernel before this. I wrote the Puffer
Advantage kernel.
So I had not done kernel like really
serious kernel dev before. Um, I never
messed with the puff uh the torch C++
API. I hate C++ in general and have very
little experience with it.
Um, I have not I've done a lot of like
system profiling and performance
optimization before, but I've never done
it like at this level with this many
moving parts across CPU and GPU.
Right? So, I've learned a ton of stuff
in the process of doing this. And I've
also made something that is now going to
accelerate the entire field cuz also
nobody else has bothered to do this ever
as it turns out.
Any new end looking to implement or want
to implement? Oh, there's always tons of
them turtle. It just depends on skill
level, right?
Probably eventually the next time I get
bored, I'm probably going to do some
sort of like Runescape boss inspired
environment. Like I tried doing that
vibe coding scream with the great M.
I'll probably just like go do that
environment properly or go do another of
the bosses properly because there's
actually some pretty cool behaviors you
can learn in that. Um
but like at the moment I'm mostly
personally I'm focused on getting this
info done and I'm kind of just curious
to see what users come up with for new
ends.
I haven't had too much time to think
about like M's lately. We're doing some
stuff right now with mazes for some of
our research side stuff, which is good.
Um, and then 2048 also ended up being a
really good end, surprisingly.
Claude is going to be really useful when
I have to update all the M's for puffer
4 because like it's not going to go mess
up all the code of the environment,
right? Like I literally just needed to
update some function signatures and some
dypes,
but that would be a massive pain to do
manually.
Run escape bots definitely had so much.
Oh, please don't break my favorite game
though, man.
I'd way rather we like can we like make
an RL bot and then train a classifier on
it and then use that to help them detect
bots and ban them all.
I've been working on trying to get
myself a pair of vertices in the
evenings.
If you know those, they were added
recently.
Anti-botting is the way interesting.
Oh, it's mainly just I don't want the
stuff I've made to also wreck my
favorite game, right? I'd rather like
the opposite.
Let's see what the line pro gives us on
this. Honestly,
I just like
I learned some really cool stuff from uh
like about game design from some of
their new content.
Like I just went, "Oh, wait. You can
just build content that way?" Really?
Huh?
Hey, look at that.
All right, we got one line left here.
It's also state out graph state graph
state out.
Well, this continuous will screw it. Why
the hell did you do this, my guy?
Why the hell is there a doc contiguous
on this?
Run a torch check on this. You don't run
a doc contiguous.
In that case,
That's only one of them though. It
should be two.
Oh, actually I know why. I know why.
That's bad though.
Now I know what happened.
I I honestly I have not botted that
game. I've played it a ton.
Um, I think it's way more interesting to
think about,
you know, what that game does for AI.
This is going to fail, right? Yeah.
Continuous. Okay.
What the heck?
Well, I'll let it do that
cuz that's nice.
It's kind of funny to me that it didn't
catch the issue though. Like this is a
very obvious issue and it just missed
it.
So, it can do that. But that's like a
very minor change.
Actually, Peru did something for this,
didn't he?
Didn't Peru do something for this?
Let me see if he did it right.
You did.
I see why you did it now.
I'm trying to think what we do about
this.
So I guess I can explain the uh the
issue.
Yeah, it can do this. So let me explain
the issue. Um so torch was doing this
really weird thing with the value
kernel. It was like using some really
inefficient pathway for output size one
for some reason and adding extra kernels
in. So I fused it together. I fused logs
and values. But obviously now when you
fuse logs and values together now the
strides aren't right anymore.
So
what do we do about that?
What do we do?
Hey, you can make these changes. These
aren't going to help though.
This is just it messing with the uh the
test now.
Literally, the most useful thing I
learned from taking MBA courses at Sloan
was that I didn't want to co-ound with
an MBA because these were some of the
stupidest people I've ever met.
One ultraeducated American can't find a
job.
Oh, I'm sure he can find a job.
Go apply to your nearest McDonald's.
He doesn't find a job that he wants.
And a lot of these people think they're
way more qualified than they are.
You know what's the meme? It was like uh
you know, hey, my last job paid me 2
million a year to do nothing. Does
anybody have an opening like this?
That's actually fine to just pass the
stride,
You probably missed out on a lot of
things.
But like I I'm not joking when I say
some of the least competent, most
insufferable, most overconfident people
I've ever met were at Sloan.
I It was like unbelievable.
They'd have like a case study and they'd
basically just be describing with
perfect competence how they would fix an
engineering company when you know it's
like I know for a fact as a programmer
that what they're saying makes literally
no sense and it would be worth nothing
the next day if they did this.
You know
it's a business
practical. Well, Puffer is a business.
Puffer is a private lab. We build high
perf sims for companies. All this stuff
is open source, but you know, our paid
stuff, we built custom sims.
I didn't do a full MBA, but I was at MIT
for my PhD and you had to take a bunch
of electives. So, I said, "All right,
whatever. I'll take some business
electives.
Okay, that's fine. So, this is going to
be the the stride added to log here.
Let me make sure I did this in the
correct order.
Yes.
So, value is last here. You see
Okay, it runs.
Cool. It runs. Now we can profile.
And that should kill off a little bit of
overhead.
And it looks like it did because that's
a fast profile.
How do we still have one elementwise
call?
Well, it removed one elementwise call.
So, um
state
no
value comes non-ontiguous then ah that's
it yep
Yeah. So that's all it has to do and
then we'll be good.
So it'll just fuse everything into this
stupid call.
That'll add like that'll be good. And
you really just need to freaking fuse
everything.
Don't open Twitter, man. Just don't open
Twitter.
All right. So, we just have the mega
kernel.
This is it. Mega kernel. Whatever.
I mean, the fact that you're doing this
kind of just like
The whole idea of like let's have a
bunch of these kernels and combine them
together. It's kind of stupid when the
whole way that we're getting Perf is
just by putting everything into the same
kernels, right? Like maybe we should
just be writing stuff in CUDA. H
there's an idea.
Mega Ultra Kernel. That'd be so funny.
We just have like, you know, the mega
kernel, the giga kernel, the mega ultra
giga kernel, and that's just like, you
know, they just do a bunch of random
stuff, and it's just like all the ops
that needed to get fused.
No semantic grouping at all purely for
PF
like when you get into small networks
like this, right? The entire system that
torches on just becomes stupid, right?
like the whole system it just becomes
very stupid
launch over it's not but the crazy thing
is this is not launch overhead man you
can get rid of the launch overhead with
graphs this is also memory bandwidth you
also duplicate memory bandwidth for
every single one of these even with
graphs this stuff is slow
The whole idea of like we're going to
launch all these ops from CPU
is kind of stupid a lot of the time. It
turns out like the CPU torch AP like
what the hell, right?
Teenage Mut Ninja. [laughter] That's
good. That's good.
Okay, this is on some like ridiculous
post, so ignore that. But this is
freaking hilarious.
get him to build puffer torch.
Sloan grad comes up with PowerPoint of
how we can increase the shareholder
value.
Uh the Sloan but the MBAs pay dude.
The either the MBAs they have to pay
themselves or they have a company that
sponsors them. PhDs get paid. MBAs have
to pay.
You see how I'm describing like really
simple transformations to the code, but
they take a ton of edits cuz everything
is just really redundant.
like people see this and they get the
sense, oh well, yeah, this is why
obviously you shouldn't be editing code.
But the thing is like most code just
should not look like this. This is crap,
Well, I mean, that's the thing, right? I
didn't have to like I didn't have to pay
for the Sloan courses because I'm a PhD
at MIT and you can take electives,
right? So like I had to take some
electives to finish my degree and you
could take whatever the hell it just had
to be unrelated to your work. So I went
and took some business courses.
What is this? Oh, this just a profile.
Okay, that's fine. Whatever. This is
again like I'm going to have to do this
again. I'm going to have to like because
there's a bunch of other stuff that now
can get merged because we've done this
this way.
Uh yeah, Roger, they were useful, but
not always because of the thing that
they were telling me, but because what I
learned by listening, not by like
listening to like, oh, you're telling me
this, I should pay attention to it, but
by like seeing, oh my gosh, you guys
have no clue whatsoever.
Um, now I will say that the one course
that was actually good and useful, I
took a business law course that was
actually good.
I wouldn't say it's interesting.
You should know some of it though.
We're going to have broken training, but
I know it needs to be fixed. So, don't
worry too much about that for now. We're
just worried about the profile numbers.
Hey, look at that.
This used to be 40% overhead.
Fast buffer.
That's 10 millie.
That's 10 mil, guys. It doesn't train
yet. We have to fix some stuff. But this
is our 10 mil.
10 million steps per second.
Man, I hope we get to commit this
tonight and have 10 million step per
second stable training.
Yeah, it turns out computers are pretty
fast and um we just suck at programming
them.
I'm get myself a new mug of tea. I'm
here to the restroom real quick and then
we are going to make all this work and
then uh if we finish that we'll start
profiling train a little bit cuz there's
going to be some stuff to fix and train
as well. Hey, I'll be right back.
I realized something, guys.
Not only did I just make this thing 10
million steps per second,
this is going to scale dramatically
better as a result.
Gotta make the faster animation faster
relative to the SPS.
That'd be funny. I do need to get some I
need to hire somebody for the uh you
know the puffer design or rather the
puffer was it modeling rig remodeling
rigging and animation.
All right, I'm going to actually let
Todd do a little bit here.
What was the third bug? I think there
was a third one.
Oh, shoot. There was a third bug. I just
forgot what it was.
AGI prompt check.
Where does thousandx speed up come from
from an engineering perspective?
Literally everywhere, turtle. Literally
everywhere. every possible thing in the
entire implementation of RL like if you
go take SP3 or clean RL even like um
torch RL every single possible thing is
slow
I think the only thing that I haven't
touched is the K blast mat because
everything else is slow
So it's not just like, oh, there's one
thing.
Nish the definition of AGI is when I can
cast fireball. Then we have AGI.
I wrote the blog post on that or the uh
the article
slow to give you stuff to do.
You better not, man. Everybody's getting
yelled at in Puffer 4 and Beyond.
Anytime there's a PR that slows anything
down, like people getting yelled at
because I'm giving everybody tools to
make their [ __ ] fast. So you make sure
slow you're getting yelled at.
Yeah, Claude's just going to reply. Do
you even live, bro?
Oh, okay. I see. It's fine.
Where were the biggest perf jumps?
Country. We have our own environments in
C with our own format. We've got our own
like crazy buffered vectorization.
We've got our own eval loop where we
have profiled it down from like it was
10% efficiency or less if you do it with
naive torch. Now we're up to like 70. Um
the whole train loop data structure is
different. The algorithm in puffer is
also different. Not to mention
everything is pseudographed in lib torch
not the python version. Um
it's like every possible thing. It's not
even like the biggest PF jumps anywhere,
at least for this version. If you're
talking about like Puffer 2, it was
doing the environments in C and then
like Puffer 3, it was fixing a lot of
the overhead that was in Python torch.
But like for Puffer 4, it's everything.
This took so much in order to make this
thing work.
And let it be known that the only reason
that Claude is even able to do any of
this crap right now is because the whole
structure of everything like the first
few kernels um the whole train loop
everything that was all done by hand.
So now it's like applying templates to
new kernels and stuff.
Ooh, we'd actually want to do that
kernel level. Jess,
what I'm going to try to do though when
I for the release, I'm going to clean up
everything so much that we are going to
be able to have custom kernels for stuff
like chess. It'll be cool.
all the code they use for non-technical
code name coworker.
Yeah, but like the model is good. Like
I'm not saying that their software is
good. Like anthropica people are nuts
anyways. Like
it's not like all the people there are
smart or remotely seen.
Maybe the first like hundred or couple
hundred people, you know, any of these
companies were good.
I'd be so happy for that. Yeah. We're
going to be able to actually like the
point of this is not now we can do
breakout at 10 mil. Now we can do
everything fast. That's the point.
bad thing. Yeah, those guys are nuts.
Like I say, I like the model. I hate the
people who built it.
Well, I should be I should be a little
careful when I say that. Um, it's tough
because so both companies like OpenAI
and Anthropic have some of the people
who are the awesomest people on the
planet and then also just some
absolutely messed up masters,
right?
Like the core scientists and engineers,
awesome. All right, the like ideologues
who want the world to look like this. I
don't even know what the heck they want.
They clearly have absolutely zero
respect whatsoever for human agency,
though.
They probably just want to replace the
species so that there's more room for
shrimp or whatever. I don't know.
Buffer live faster than Jackson. Oh
yeah, massively dude. Massively faster.
You're kind of just trolling if you're
doing your stuff in Jacks. Honestly,
marketing guys.
I don't know why they have in PR guys
like
I don't know if this needs to be a N64.
We'll look at this thing. But I like
this should not change meaningfully the
um compute time. I don't think.
10 mil. But we still have perf bug. I
mean, we still have um correctness bug
somehow.
So, that will end up being sub 15 second
maybe. How did you go about wanting to
speed up RL? How did you learn all this?
I mean, I've been doing RL since 2017,
18. It's been a while. Um, I mean, I did
my whole PhD on neural MMO, right? And I
wrote what was back then, uh, the
fastest environment of that complexity,
I would say, and I came up with a bunch
of techniques for efficiency back then
that were crap compared to what we have
now. You know, I spent a lot of time
thinking about infrastructure to support
complex and interesting Ms. And then
after my PhD, I was thinking, okay,
well, if I can get RL to sort of work on
some of these more complex ends, can I
get it working more stably on simpler
ends?
And I mean, from there, I very quickly
just started discovering as soon as I
got out of academia, how just doing some
good low-level edge will let you just
run right over everything else in the
field.
like it's really really unoptimized and
I did a lot of optimization for an
academic during my PhD but like when you
really start to start going lower level
it's just follow the gradient man like
you keep doing this stuff the stuff gets
faster stuff gets more stable so I kept
doing it for the last two years
and I've learned a ton and I made RL a
heck of a lot faster and I built a
company around it
Would it be possible for communic Wait
and I think I missed a message. They had
a task two agents working together to do
with good timing.
Communication develop. Yes, you can
totally get communication Jess emerging
communication 100%.
I think I missed one of your message
though, so I don't know the exact
setting under which you uh were
describing. In general though, yes.
Okay. Well, this is a pain because this
is broken.
Broken. Not good.
Okay, so 3.9 with no optimizations on
whatsoever.
Oh yeah, we didn't uncomment the yellow.
We probably need to do that.
Doesn't look like it needs it that badly
though.
Yeah, it doesn't look like it really
cares that much. Cool. Uh
send and receive super
you can get emerging communication quite
easily. Jess
there's nothing that special about it.
I don't know. We ascribe a lot of value
to things that like are rare to emerge
among animals or among people or
whatever, but like very often actually
it's it's like very easy to learn these
things.
You kind of just need the good RL setup
and then you steamroll
5.4. Now we need our custom kernels. The
problem
so something is free with one of the
kernels.
Okay, this one's disabled. We know that
this one is good.
Fun research ends post chess. Oh, tons,
man.
I mean, if you can get selfplay, if you
get log linear ELO curve with like some
reasonable amount of compute on chess
though
and like you can figure some stuff out
about selfplay with Spencer, that'll be
a massive contribution
already
more than qualify you for professional
stuff for sure. And we have a lot of
projects from there, but a lot of the
projects are really going to depend on
the outcome of 40 at this point. There's
some stuff around exploration that's
pretty tough that we have uh some active
collaborations on.
There's the uh the state based stuff
like the go explore style exploration
stuff for puffer 5 that's really
important and that needs to be done
correctly.
I think there's actually because of this
kernel stuff I've done I think there's
some room for some fundamental
architecture work.
This one disabled and this one is good.
This flag, dude. Flag. Disabled flag.
What makes chess complicated? Uh,
competitive selfplay is hard.
All right, this is nine 95
and uh yeah, this this kernel screw up
somehow.
big action space. Uh I don't actually
ever take like action space size is pure
difficulty.
It's it's a very misleading metric. It's
used to nerd snipe a whole bunch.
Okay, so this is broken even with
computer graphs off.
probably doesn't get no I was just going
to say it doesn't get traced
it's kind of tough Jeff because like you
can probably come up with some dumb ends
that require ire a lot of compute and
scale log linear but like log linear
compute scaling like nice curve on
compute up to continuing to improve for
a very long time is a good sign. Um this
is one of the things we just like about
games because we kind of just understand
okay there's a lot going on here it's
complex.
If you try to come up with like a
mathematical definition of complexity
you're going to get something that's
formal but useless is the problem.
that real quick.
Try that.
Yeah, there there's so much stuff I
could write chess.
It's tough because like you see right
when I'm making progress in one area,
I'm always behind on something else. And
at the moment, it's just been in order
to get puffer to be 10 mil steps per
second, I just have to devote a ton of
time to it
because like who the hell else is going
to help me make puffer 10 mil SPS?
Actually, you know, Peru did quite a bit
like um a lot of Peruse code was quite
helpful, especially today with some of
the like the last couple kernels.
Pretty good.
Do you sponsor something extraordinary
on GitHub? Uh I sponsor Ray. There's one
project.
because we use Ray Lib in um all of our
stuff. It's the best damn library ever.
I've learned so much from Raison.
Awesome programmer. And you should know
I don't give praise lightly.
Wait, let me read this message. One
second.
Oops.
I mean, I am average height. I don't
vape. My teeth are fine.
No anime. Whatever the hell, I guess,
unless you count.
I mean, I got pretty lofty everything,
but I'd say that's more uh
I read like a lot of sci-fi and fantasy
stuff.
And I lift. And I run. Well, there you
go.
Beer's okay. Don't have to do much.
All right. There we go. This is This is
basically clean.
Oh, it is 10 mil.
It's on the C 10 mil.
Or we can go profile some other stuff
now, right?
optimizations would get us there as
well.
How long have you been running? Is there
a 10x speed up there? I've been running
for well I ran across country when I was
growing up. I was not good at it. Uh
I've been running actively the last
threeish years. And is there a 10x speed
up there?
No. I recently I got to be I think I'm a
little bit faster now than I was when I
was in high school, but I weigh 40 lbs
more now. So it's a lot harder.
Uh,
hey guys. Can I just like
It's lower. Oh, no. It's about the same.
It's just fluctuating. Cool.
I just wanted to see if I could get a
cheeky 10 mil.
I think I will have to uh to profile our
effect a little bit.
It should be faster. But I think in the
meantime what we do Yes.
Oh, I forgot to zero the state as well.
Yeah, zero state.
That's not going to take bite out of
perf, though. Have you played any MMOs
recently? I unfortunately did download
Runescape again. So, I've been uh trying
to get my veric trends in the evening.
That's what I've been doing.
But I've also been getting a heck of a
lot of good progress in on kernel dev on
this and on client MS too. So,
I have a little break once in a while.
channel.
Don't I stream enough, dude? I think I'm
in front of this camera enough hours
today.
If some viewers want to come do some
raids or something, we can set something
up for that, though.
I got to relearn chambers at some point.
I used that used to be my best piece of
content.
Putting you in the background makes me
less way lazy. All
right, look at all these gross element
wise ops left.
Oh,
this one
not as bad as it used to be.
But check this out, folks. Look at all
this overhead we have, right?
once I get bored of um
I mean do you have an account that's
like chambers [clears throat] ready?
You could always do that and do some
viewer rates. That'd be fun. I really
like that game.
It's such a fun game. And it's also just
so cool for AI. Like so many of the
things just down to the level of what of
how it is implemented at the tick by
tick level is so good for AI.
All right. So we have all this [ __ ]
right? Like we've got right here. This
is 14%.
Yeah, we got 20% overhead right here
without even looking at these two.
Do you play chess? I'm absolutely
terrible at chess.
We're going to do what's watch this.
We're going to do like this.
Muan
reallocates.
Oh, I did not check that one, Rob. I've
been doing something else today. I've
been optimizing.
They're quite other a few other things
that need optimizing that I've been
doing first. We're pretty close to 10
mil.
They said yields 1500. I say my ELO is
1500. I'm nowhere near 1500. I suck.
That was someone else in the chat, I
think. Was that like I don't know if
that was Jess or Spencer or somebody.
We'll do this just to be absolutely
There.
Yeah, we cut down um I think we cut
between half and 2/3 overhead today from
eval. Now, there's still a bunch of it
in train. So, I'm looking at this now.
It's almost 4. I got a little time.
47 mil when you have all the other stuff
this disabled
of course that's without do so
open code Oh,
okay.
This tells us another story, doesn't it?
When you take out dotbackward
fuse scan very slow,
but that doesn't really help us because
we can't do much about that right now.
it's really only gotten bad in the last
few months.
I'm gonna let Claude look at this and
I'm going to use the restroom.
Um,
I think we're just going to have to fuse
some more crap,
but I'll just add it for now.
You know what? I actually I bet I know
what this is.
right? These suck right here. These are
going to trigger element wise.
can look at the report and I'll be a
Mirror.
I think we should.
Do we need to do anything else other
than that?
I think I can get it to do this
cuz this doesn't need grats.
that it doesn't actually get used other
than right here.
so this is towards the end of the day
where I have to not get lazy and let it
do way too much at once. Um,
again, this what I'm doing here is
incredibly verifiable and it has
template. It's basically template
matching the existing thing. Um,
the only thing I probably should be a
little careful with is
I mean the multinnomial op, but I
believe that it just it has the same one
as the soft max, doesn't it?
Oh, it's going to mess up a new beta.
I'm sure we'll have to fix that.
That's fun.
a good spot.
He'd be fun to chat with about RL. I
think you'd get a kick out of it.
Yeah, these are actually annoying
because there's
It's a bunch of reductions, right?
Okay. Okay. Hang on. Hang on.
Yeah, that's a whole bunch of annoying
mobs.
Okay, I definitely tried to make it do
way too much.
I'm not 1500, dude. I'm trash at the
chest. Okay,
it's fine. I do. All right.
Uh
It's still going to be a good
environment.
This off is super annoying if you look
at it right.
Let me see how many of these ops we
need.
pretty damn much. 10 mil um 9.9 10.0
something like that.
I'm looking at the trade loop seeing if
we can cut some fluff off of it.
M min Rex
min GPU Rex. Um have an Nvidia GPU.
I don't know. This one has this machine.
Well, I'm testing on a 5090 machine uh
which is going to be 10 mil SPS for
Puffer 4. But like a 5070 is still going
to be four or five mil, probably more.
So
puffer is very fast.
Without puffer, you're screwed though
because nothing else is fast and nothing
else like the hardware doesn't even help
you. Almost everything is just so
inefficient.
What's the most important GPU spec? What
do you mean?
Like floss. Just get a consumer card. If
you mean the VRAM, no, you don't need
the VRAM.
It's very, very low on VRAM usage.
Well, you're not going to be able to
tell from that.
You're pretty much best off just getting
like a good consumer card. If you want
to try the stuff out, you can rent these
cards on BAS for like somewhere between
9 and 50 cents an hour depending on the
card. Though, a lot of those are either
underclocked or it's otherwise screwy.
Yeah. See, this gets comp this gets
really annoyingly complicated, doesn't
it?
We should actually test this without the
indices.
I think I know what this is going to end
up looking like though. Anyways,
and puffer five is going to get even
faster if I'm right.
it's really easy to overuse it.
It really encourages you to be very
lazy, which is very bad.
The stuff I'm doing right now is very
boilerplate heavy and also very strongly
verifiable.
See, like it's so dumb.
We should just do this, right?
I just want to see if like some of the
really weird line items disappear in the
profile.
Well, I mean,
I don't even know what to say to that.
Okay, look, this is this is
substantially better.
We still have this element wise kernel
but actually very few pulls of it.
So actually presumably this is now
outside the loop.
Outside the loop. Maybe outside the
loop.
I think so. Outside the loop.
Vectorized gather kernel.
So this is our indexing overhead. All
right.
max.
What?
Now we're doing something different,
dude.
We're doing something different here.
Okay, this is what we want, right?
Temporary continuous lights.
This is good, right?
this gets commented or no, this is going
to get updated
to be like narrow or whatever
slice here.
So, pretty much what we're doing here,
it's the same thing we did with board
where we're just going to keep stripping
stuff down until we end up with like
very small number of line profile items
that we can track and then just cutting
out redundant stuff.
I think though that this is kind of an
algorithmic level thing where the
indexing off is just very stupid
and we're just wasting some time on it
until we come up with something better.
Okay. See, so we still have
a bunch of calls.
Let's see what uh what element wise we
have.
I think that like the squeeze and the
like transpose there lots of these
things that need to be
need to be fixed.
Okay,
we'll just if Claude's going to be
stupid, we'll do it myself.
I'll do it myself.
much just need to figure out every
possible source of
random overhead.
It doesn't contain any data
um because we skipped the first 3
seconds.
Wouldn't it be nice if RL were this
fast? Yeah, that's not happening though.
[laughter]
That one would be hard.
65 mil would be um I can get eval to be
65 mil with big batch there's no problem
Too much data though from this
apparently. Too many ops.
Now we'll fix that.
Goes faster.
See if this gives me anything
interesting though.
and it's several per um
per iteration. You see?
stupid internet.
Okay.
Oh yeah, this a good time to remind
people. Please feed the puff for a star.
He's hungry. 488.
Almost to 5k.
Maybe when we hit 5k, I'll put some
effort to get a stable pre-release for
you all.
Realistically, it's just a ton of work.
That's the problem.
It's just a stupid amount of work.
All right. What we got?
I see. I see.
Uh why do we have this many?
Wait, this is not even one per
iteration.
Well, this is the graphing that's
getting picked up. So, we ignore that.
Uh, this one is a lot.
This one is a lot.
Why is there a um giant giant element
wise kernel here?
What would this be?
We definitely need to fix a couple
things.
Uh there's also like almost nothing left
here.
So
it's close forward train and it gets
diffused loss.
I wonder if this is actually trace
overhead.
That'd be kind of silly if I did that,
right?
I mean, we still this is not trace
overhead, right? But
It's very odd
over just did not go away.
I really This is just at this point
about making sure we know where all the
overhead is at the very least, you know.
Just have to make sure though that this
is not trace overhead.
We should probably be able to guess from
the counts, right?
Phil bumper.
Oh, wait. Here it is. Right. Look.
Yeah. So let's just give it the GPU per
song.
Bill Fter.
So, there is
Oh, wait. There's a ton of these fill
ops. You see it?
Yeah, it's filled.
Bunary funer. I don't know what this is.
Bunary funer. Imple
no cast launch clamp scaler. We got a
few of these.
I wonder if it's this.
No, cuz it's outside the loop.
Oh,
it's going to be in here.
Yeah, it's going to be in here 100%.
I forgot.
That's element wise right there.
And then the next one
was right here.
Does contiguous ops are bad for sure.
Photographing eliminates torch checks.
But
Okay, they're 900 some odd epochs.
So 800 something could be the one. Like
those don't matter if it's 800
something. That's going to be inside the
loop.
takes forever profiles.
Just make a plan then while I wait.
I think next we're going to do
We're going to reenable all the copies
because they shouldn't add any like once
we have no element wise.
We'll reenable all the copies.
this freaking poly market. What? People
are betting this.
I mean, that would be a huge failure if
they do that, right? They'd lose the
consumer market.
I guess it depends on what happened to
AMD.
Okay.
[sighs]
I don't want to do puffer lip poly
market or else gambling is cancer.
Same number, right?
Oh, this one as well.
bad.
This is not every single batch though.
DT type conversions,
double copies.
I hope you get some good stuff out of
that.
You know, do some homework. Make sure
you're
doing stuff appropriately.
What do we freaking do with this
DT type conversions? 5,000 DType
conversions. Really?
Oh, you dummy. It's probably right here,
you stupid
something up here.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is totally
going to be something stupid up here.
We just need that profiler to run faster
as well. So why don't we work on that?
Just need to get this to be a fast pair
loop.
We can profile properly.
>> [sighs]
>> Just need to get this thing to a fast
profile loop so I can actually just get
it to not have the element wise ops in
there.
Oh shoot. If we don't No, if we don't
graph, it's still fine. If we don't
graph, it's still fine. The kernels
with Kuda grabs off
actually. You know what we can do? I
know what we can do.
I think this will be fine because we're
not going to trace now.
There,
that should work. We'll see.
It's crazy that even that is not fast
though to collect the data.
It's so weird.
It's going to be so weird.
it still take forever to generate
reports.
I don't understand what the hell
take forever.
I mean, presumably something's broken.
Wait for it.
I think like the torch initialization
breaks or some [ __ ]
I honestly don't know what the hell's
broken with it.
Stupid profile script
Well, this should be able to run profile
now.
Let's see if that works.
I'll actually let this run for a bit.
Roll up graph replay.
Train forward graph replay.
Nothing in this call. Nothing in this.
Perfect.
So, this is the exact profile we want.
It'll just Oh, there it goes.
That thing just takes forever and it's
kind of difficult to get them in
profile, but
let's see what this does.
Because the thing I forgotten is that we
actually had not profiled the um the
train time forward pass. It's a
different forward pass for training
time.
Is there any actually interesting
research on here?
Wait, sample logic kernel is called um
that's not called in back. No, it is
called in back, right?
this
policy forward train gets called
uh which does not have sample logs right
well that's interesting then
so wait then Yes.
full day stream. I've been live for 8
hours. A little longer.
And there's only one element wise.
That's good. It's a tiny one as well.
Oh, you know what? I know what this is.
This has got to be the RNG, right
that's got to be the RNG, right? On
sample logs.
All right.
Um, it's a little annoying to have to do
that, but
And how confident am I? I'm very
confident, right? This is it.
and then this will be clean profile
stupid thing
and it'll be like a you know one 2%
gain.
And then we'll rebuild this. We'll see
no element wise kernels.
Um, and then once we see that,
we uncomment the
unindex copies.
That one should work.
And then, well, we've kind of commented
a lot of crap, right? But
it's fine.
We'll definitely be getting over 10 mil
now. So that's that question is settled.
This is the sanity. If this works, we
have sanity.
Now, unfortunately, there's still a
whole bunch of crap that we have not
been able to um get all the little
annoying kernels out of.
But there's quite a bit we can do with
just this. And
there's a lot we can do with just this.
So for instance,
sample logic fless. Okay, look, you see
there are zero element wise kernels.
And if I group this by base, it's even
cleaner.
63% matable time. View scan forward. I'm
in gregate p loss sample logs, right?
Super clean profile.
We're going to add the backwards in and
make sure that this isn't messed up. I
like this is going to be slow, but
there's not much else I can really do.
Uh there's not a good way to make this
test faster that's relatively
straightforward either.
That's fine. We'll just put in a little
bit of time on this.
bet I can make it.
I bet you I can make it.
Bet you just make the duration 3
seconds.
Just needs 3 seconds of data. That'll
probably be nice and fast. We'll see.
So without all the copies and without
the muon overhead, we're over 11 mill.
Oh yeah, look at that. Way faster
report. Perfect.
This is going to be way less painful
in two minute cycle. Good.
Element wise kernel.
Yo, you're not supposed to have that
there.
So that one element wise
vectorzed element wise.
Okay. So here let's say
What do we have then? It's reduce
kernel.
We also have this reduce kernel. Wait.
Yeah. Reduce kernel
element wise kernel
split.
Yeah. So we got like look at these. One,
two, three. This is extra percent and a
half.
Not like every time I do literally
anything, Torch bleeds a couple%.
It's not called. We do not zero the
ground.
loss reduction.
But there shouldn't be a loss
We just call backward on it. There's no
reduction
1,700.
Well, that's not a lot of them.
We also have vectorized element wise.
Oh, wait. We're looking over here. Okay.
So, we have
386 3840.
This looks to me like it's in the fuse
scan, right?
There's an extra element wise off in
fuse scan most likely.
Is this fuse scan?
Nobody.
Okay, so this is probably in that one.
And then
split reduced. I actually have no idea
what this is in.
Oh, but then the reduced kernel is
totally in the PO loss, right?
Dota is the best result in our though as
of time of recording. Best result in our
Blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
and see I can spot it in the meantime.
It could very easily be one of these
contiguous
pulse.
and I'll play with this more tomorrow
morning most likely after maybe tonight.
We'll see.
that we can get the like the doc
contiguous. I think we're just going to
remove most of these because you just
need to have your buffers contiguous
wherever possible.
Contiguous is nice to make sure your
stuff works, but
I'd rather People have to do it manually
if they want to be slow. Default path is
fast and safe.
Don't worry about profile.
We'll see how this does.
I think they should at least get one of
them.
And it just shows you though like
literally any individual op that you
leak you'll leak a percentage of perf
And that's actually really way worse
than just making one catastrophic error
because then like you know this is what
hap this is what you have to do in order
to get those 1%s back.
It's easy to catch catastrophic errors
like oh the profile slot can't do
anything.
Yeah, that means you got to rewrite the
whole bloody thing is what that means.
Uh, one of them is gone.
Yeah, the PP the PO loss reduction
kernel is gone.
Let's go try the element wise thing real
quick.
I mean, it still runs.
The torch check would catch that.
Oh, yeah. This is a crouch off, isn't
it?
I'm going to go check in the meantime
cuz it could also be in here.
That's not an element wise call, right?
Here's the training path.
Fused cam.
I guess it could also be in the um
it could be in here maybe.
I don't see anything that would be it
here though.
I don't see any element wise though. Do
you
nothing that would match that
size? No.
Should we then gate? No.
Yeah. I don't see what else this would
be.
Do you scam?
Let's go check the colonel again. And we
can like we can also just comment out.
Oops.
Yeah, we can also comment out like the
whole thing if we need to.
So weird.
Well, I mean, we can also just like take
the view scan out, right?
Hasn't found anything. So, I think
probably
I'll let this do this for a bit, but um
I think probably we check this off
explicitly.
vectorized element was
this one
direct copy CUDA kernel. Oh, it's a
cast.
This is nice though that we can do it
like this.
There it is.
So this is direct copy colonel cuda
oper the hell C++ nonsense man.
No cast direct copy.
I bet it's this thing.
But I don't know why this would be a
kernel.
So,
how do we do it here?
St. This is how we do it here.
That is probably what it would be for a
not contiguous, right?
So you can just grab. Now I know the CSV
actually does contain the full names.
I run it
and we'll see what we get.
I mean I don't think it would be like a
cop it would be like a contiguous or
some [ __ ] right
it's going to be like some dumb implicit
op
just one way to get the line number in
the fra and source.
You can do that, but like
I don't think that helps.
I doubt that changes anything.
I guess it could technically be one of
them. Pretty awkward.
We're very close either way.
10 mil.
Actually, don't know if that's the same
number of instances.
I can probably come up with a much
better test though for this stuff.
I'm pretty happy with the progress we
made on this. I'd like to have this
actually like in a runnable state
though. Um, so let's just go see if I
can do that real quick.
So, I got to be done for the day. I'd
like to have this committed runnable.
Okay, so the video saving just decided
to be complete crap apparently and just
not saved correctly. Lovely.
Okay. But yeah, my reporter just sucks
for some stupid reason.
We are all set.
Let's commit this so I don't lose
anything.
There's still some optimization to be
done, I'm sure, but I'm kind of sick of
it. So, I think that the rest of it's
going to be done as part of the cleanup,
you know,
cuz I'll be sure that I'll be having um
better benchmarking in the process of
doing the release cleanup.
But there we go.
Promise kept. 10 million step per second
training will be coming to RL.
I think um by the time I've cleaned
everything up, I'll have it like, you
know, over 10 mil by a bit. So, it's
it's a clean 10 mil. It's not me
bullshitting it, you know. It's not
going to be 95 or something. We'll
probably make sure it's at least 105.
Um,
yeah. Turns out stuff is really, really
fast if you just don't waste all your
compute.
I'm going to go get some food. I've been
live for over nine hours at this point.
Um,
this is not going to be like this was
not one of the super fun active streams.
This was one of the just like work on a
bunch of stuff until things make sense
streams.
We are
what 1.5 million SPS faster than when we
started. 1 million SPS starter,
whatever. We're faster.
If you're interested in my work and
would like to support it for absolutely
free, please just feed this puffer fish
a star on GitHub. It really helps me
out. We're almost to 5K.
You can join the Discord to get
involved.
You can follow me on X for more
reinforcement learning content.
Thank you, Finn. It's going to be a lot
more work to get this thing fully
cleaned up, but at least it is insight
now. You know, it's real. It exists.
Okay, folks. Good night. I'm getting
food. Um, I